ونحييكم الى نقاشي ملفنا الاول لا تزالوا
تداعيات الانفجارات القويه التي هزت مدينه
اصفهان الايرانيه قبل ايام مستهدفه مصنع
عسكريا مستمرا حيث شهدت المدينه هجوم
بطائرات المسيره على مجمع صناعي تبعا
لوزاره الدفاع وفق اعلان نظام طهران وزاره
الدفاع الايرانيه افادت بان ثلاثه مسيرات
من طراز اكواد كوبر محمله بقنا بلا صغيره
نفذت الهجوم ما يرجح نظريه تنفيذه من داخل
ايران منظومه الدفاع الجوي الايرانيه قالت
انها اسقطت احدى المسيارات وحصره مسيراتان
وانفجرته ولم يتسبب الهجوم وفقا لنظام
طهران في وقوع اصابات وتم تسجيله واضرار
في احد المباني ومنذ اعلان او الاعلان عن
الهجوم لم يتوقف الصد والرد ايران اتهمت
اسرائيل علنا بين الكنافه البنتاجون طلوعه
في الهجوم ملمحا الى وقوف اسرائيل وراء
هذا الهجوم فيما عبرت اوكرانيا عن سعادتها
بهذه الضربه
اصفها صحيفه يورك تايمز تقول ان السيارات
التي استهدفت مواقع باصفهان يعتقد انها
انطلقت من داخل ايران ايران اتهمت اسرائيل
علنا بوقوفها وراء الهجوم
امريكيون ضربه اصفهان نفذتها اسرائيل كبار
المساعدين هجوم اصفهان بالحرب الاوكرانيه
بما يجري على الارض ايران استدعت القائمه
بالاعمال الاكرانيه
الحكومه الاوكرانيه تدريئه ساحتها يؤكد
انها شركه في الضربه التي نفذتها اسرائيل
اصفها وعد احدى اهم المدن الايرانيه في
الصناعات العسكريه تضم منشاه لا تنسى
الشهيره اهم المنشات الايرانيه النوويه
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من نيويورك عبر
سكايب توني ببدران للبحث في مركز الدفاع
عن الديمقراطيات ومن تل ابيب عبر زوم
فيتار مستشار سابق اهلا بكم ضيوفي واسمحوا
لي ان ابدا من تل ابيب معك السيده فيتار
السؤال المطروح في هذه المرحله خاصه بان
البعض يعتبر بان هذه الضربه كانت ضربه
موجعه لايران اسرائيل تتوقع ردا معينه
لحد هلا اسرائيل ما اخذت مسؤوليه بشكل
رسمي على هذا الهجوم الداخليه
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لهذه الموضوع
لازم نكون بكل صراحه
قديمه
اعتمادتها حتى بعد الاغتيالات بعد ضرب
اخرى كانت ايران
قصفت
مثلا في 2020
واسرائيل يعني لم تصرح
انك تحدثت عن الجانب الامريكي وهنا سؤال
لك سيد طوني لماذا الجانب الامريكي هذه
المره اعلن بعد ساعات قليله وحتى ان البعض
همم تحدث عن مسؤوليه الجانب الامريكي في
هذه ضربات وكان هناك تعاونا اسرائيليا
امريكيا
توني تسمعني
ممتاز
ااه في محاوله بعد التمرين العسكري
ونوع من الدعايه انه تمرين العسكري
المشترك بين القوه الامريكيه والاسرائيليه
هو يوجه رساله الى ايران انه حاول تعاون
عسكري لضرب هذا الشيء نسيته ومصادر مقرب
جدا من اداره اوباما همم
وهو على فم السفير الاسبق لاداره اوباما
في اسرائيل الذي هو يعني النوع من ناطق
شبه رسمي بما يتعلق باسرائيل اللي اعلن
انه ابدا هذه ما بالعكس عطاها غير طبيعي
تم الامتحان هذه النظريه عندما صارت
الضربه باصفهان انه دغري الاداره تنصلت
منه وتلصلت من انه الى اي علاقه
يخص الحرب باوكرانيا لانه كان في نوع من
دعايه من الجانب ال ال بتاع الاسرائيل
انهاء طريقه
للاسرائيليين انه
يتفادوا الضغوط الامريكيه لادخال لجون في
الحرب ضد روسيه في اوكرانيا انه هي ضربت
همم الطرق يا اللي بتساعد المسيرات
وبتساعد فيها ايران روسيه دون انه تتورط
همم
السيارات
او على الاقل
اسرائيل ولكن تحدثت عن المناورات ال- همم
السائليه الامريكيه اليس من الغريب
سيدتوني ان تكون هذه المناورات التي حاكت
مواقع ايرانيه ان تسبق هذه الضربه الموجعه
لايران لاسبوع فقط
نعم انا اظن انه كان في محاوله لرابط
هالمساله مش من الجانب الاميري كان في
يمكن بعض الناس بالجانب الامريكي عم بتجرب
انه تغطي انه هي بعدها عم تعطي مساعدات
وفي دائما
جوزيه امريكيه انه لا بسبب المفاوضات تعثر
المفاوضات انه نحنا
كل الخيارات مفتوحه والى ما هنالك ان ما
مثل برجع بقول قالوا السفير الاسبق
الامريكي في في اسرائيل انه هذه مجرد
لاعاده همم الايرانيين الى المفاوضات ان
محطه هايدي الرساله فشلت لانه شيء انه
صارت الدار باسوان اتنصلت منك الاداره
كليه همم للضربه وعلقت الاسرائيليين
وتركتهم بره واعلن انهن مسؤوليتهن عنا
وتركتهم لمواجهتها همم بمفردهم يعني حتى
هذه الدع
ايه
ما المنتظر يعني سيد افيتار اليوم لما
نتحدث عن همم قراءه البعض يقول بان هذه
الضربه هي اللي دفع ايران للعوده
للمفاوضات هل تعتقد بان ايران ستسلم بهذا
الامر وتعود المفاوضات او انا ايران قد
تتخذ قرارات اخرى غير الصمت الذي اعتمدته
لفتره طويله بعد ضرب مختلف منشاتها لبعض
يتحدث عن خيارنا عسكري
حسب التخليل الاسرائيلي والامريكي يا زينب
بس حسنا حسب التقرير الاسرائيلي في صعوبات
كثيره
بموضوع
الرجعه او العوده لاتفاق بين امريكا و
اوروبا وايران
نحنا هون في اسرائيل المخللين بيقول له
حسب
التنزيمات الامنيه
انه في صعوبات كثيره بالنسبه لتجديد
الاتفاق بين الجانبين وعشان هيك في قال لك
اسرائيلي جدي من همم
الايراني الى برنامج نوويه همم وفي كمان
تفكير انه همم يكون همم صعب جدا ليه مانع
اي تقدم ايراني غير الخيار العسكري عناته
في همم
او في مصلحه
اسرائيليه ل اا التفكير من البدايه من
الاول
وخلينا نقول التشكيل استراتيجيه جديده
بالنسبه
لتحديد
النووي الايراني وفي كمان ان هي همم
اسرائيليه
لتعزيز وتكبير التنسيق والتعاون المشترك
بين اسرائيل وامريكا بالنسبه لهذه الموضوع
عشان ما في لحد هلا ما في سياسه همم كامله
مشتركه للجنبيه
قلت بانه هناك محاوله للزوج بامريكا ليكون
هناك تحالف او اللي فاهم بان هناك تحالف
اسرائيلي همم امريكي للضغط على ايران
بتصور كان في نوع من المحاوله انه ما برجع
يعني اذا اذا بتسمحي لي اقرا لك الاقتباس
الي قالوا السفير لانه النقط تبعوله كثير
محدده ومهمه بتصور قال انه التمرين
العسكري المناوره هي تشير الى تحول الى
استراتيجيه ترضع قد تكون ضروريه اذا ظلت
ايران دوله عتبه نوويه
دود الاتفاق النووي واحد
ثانيا يوفر
يمكن ان تسهل العوده الى الدبلوماسيه
اثنين
الثالثه كثير مهمه انه همم مضيف انه عمق
الطعاون المطلوب من خلال التمرين المكثف
يمكن ان يجعل من غير المرجع من غير المرجح
ان يتصرف طرف بشكل مستقل دون تنسيق وثيق
مع الاخر يعني هذه كارثه اللي هي رساله
عكس التعاون الاسرائيلي الامريكي في ضرب
العراق
تحول الى استراتيجيه لانه يمكن انه لا
يوصل اتفاق وبالت
شو يعني ان تصبح اقرار امريكي بان ايران
اصبحت دوله عتبه نوويه وبالتالي هناك
انتقال الى استراتيجيه ترضع لدوله على
عتبه
هذه رسائل امريكيه ما الى ابدا اي علاقه
بيضرب او بالتعاون مع اسرائيل لضرب
المنشات النوويه او لتغيير استراتيجيه
بشكل
ايران من الوصول الى الى هذه المرحله يعني
هذه كانت رساله كثير
من احد الاشخاص من من في صلب يعني اداره
اوباما السابقه
والمهتمين بالمسائل يعني الامور متعلقه
لاسرائيل ولكن سيد افيتار الا ترى بان همم
امريكا كذلك لديها مصالح قد توازن مصالح
الاسرائيليه في ضرب المنشات النوعيه تحدث
منذ قليل سيتوني على المسيارات وكانت هناك
تحضيرات امريكيه من تزويد ايران لروسيا
بهذه المسيارات التي تصاعد همم جدا لانها
مسيرات غير مكلفه ولكن تصدي لها مكلف
للغايه همم فهل تعتقد حضرتك بانه هناك دور
قد يكون امريكا في هذه العمليه
انا بفكر انه امم امريكا موجوده ااا في في
كمان يعني علاقه مباشره
[موسيقى]
على كل عمليه وعمليه وعلى كل الاجراءات
الاسرائيليه ضد ايران في كل الجبهات يا في
جبل الشماليه عراق سوريا
هذه الموضوع بس اذني اسرائيل اييه بتفكر
انه الخيار للسياسي وديبلوماسي همم
اقبليغان ايه
يتوفى يعني مات ما في اي امكانيه لتجديد
جدي هذه الخيار وعشان هيك تمشي سهيل تمشي
بيتاخذته كل سنهوات العسكريه همم
والاستعدادات العسكريه من كل النواحي همم
[موسيقى]
في مصلحه اسرائيليه لضم الامريكان بكل
البرنامج وبكل الاجراءات همم القادمه
وشغل اشتراك وتعاون كامل بموضوع
الاستخبارات والمعلومات الاستخباريه
داخل المصادر الاسرائيلي يا داخل الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهمم بالنسبه
لتطورات الايرانيه وبالنسبه لامكانيات
الهجوم والمانيا ايراني
يبقى سؤال كيف سترد ايران
الرد الايراني
مستمر حتى
قبل اذا بدك لانه كل الاشياء عم بنشوفها
بالطفل الغربيه حتى في القدس المحاولات من
قبل
الجهاد منظمه الجهاد الاسلامي»
على ملي الشتائب على الايرانيين مش اكثر
ولا اقل بقى همم انه مساله انه الهجوم هلا
من اي همم جبهه ثاني طبعا همم ماذون وضع
همم ايران في الجبهات ال- ال- يعني بسوريا
مثلا يد اسرائيل مطلقه كليه همم في سوريا
في لبنان
[موسيقى]
احوالهم على قد ما بتصور انه الحزب بوارد
انه يجرب شغلي هلا انما يعني كمان وظيفه
الحزم مش هيرد عليك وظيفه الحزم شيء ثاني
همم
القطاعات الفلسطينيه واحد اثنان همم في
همم يعني ضربات ال- ال- انحاء العالم في
امريكا اللاتينيه انما همم
تسيطر عليها طيب
حتى الفكره سيكتفي بهذا القدر على ان يكون
هذا النقاش او تكون بقيه لهذا النقاش ولكن
في مواعيد اخرى او شكرا لكم جزيل الشكر من
نيويورك طوني بدرنا الباحث في مركز الدفاع
عن الديمقراطيسيات من تل ابيب افيتار
مستشار امنيه